>> I AM GREG GUTFELD AND JUAN
WILLIAMS AND EMILY.
REMEMBER ALL OF THOSE RIGHTEOUS
TIMES GOING AFTER TRUMP FOR NOT
WEARING A MASK.
HE IS A ROLE MODEL.
HE IS KILLING PEOPLE.
OF COURSE AWAY FROM THE CAMERAS
THEY WERE DOING SOMETHING ELSE.
THAT’S THE DIFFERENT BETWEEN
TRUMP AND POLITICIANS.
WITH TRUMP WHEN YOU SEE IS WHAT
YOU GET.
THE OTHERS, WELL THEY ARE
POLITICIANS LIKE NANCY PELOSI
CAUGHT AT A HAIR SALON DESPITE
LAWS KEEPING THEM CLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC.
NANCY SAID THIS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE BY BRINGING
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE THERE, NO
MASKS AND THE DISTANCING.
HE SLAPS SCIENCE RIGHT IN THE
FACE AND WHAT A BAD EXAMPLE THAT
WAS.
>> WHAT A BAD EXAMPLE.
SHE SHOULD KNOW.
AND THE PHILADELPHIA MAYOR
CAUGHT EATING INSIDE
A RESTAURANT WHILE HIS CITY
DANNED INDOOR DINING.
-- BANNED.
WHY DO PEOPLE SEEK POLITICAL
POWER?
IT’S TO INCREASE THEIR QUALITY
OF LIFE TO ALLOW THEM IMMUNITY
FROM THE LAWS THEY ENFORCE.
IT’S THE SPECIAL PASS FOR THE
BEST SEAT IN THE HOUSE AND TO BE
ABLE TO RUN RED LIGHTS TO GET
THE GYM ACROSS TOWN.
IF YOU TALK THE TALK, THERE IS
NO NEED TO WALK THE WALK.
ASK JOE BIDEN.
POLITICS GETS YOU PERKS AND
FAME.
LOOK AT THE CLINTON BROOD WHO
EXPECTED AND GOT MILLIONS AFTER
LANGUISHING IN TAXPAYER FUNDED
PROPERTY.
AND THE OBAMAS NETFLIX CAT FATS.
WHAT IS TRUMP IN THIS DID THE
MEDIA ASK THAT?
NO THEY WERE TRYING TO SCORE
TICKETS TO HAMILTON.
WE HAVE A TAPE OF NANCY PELOSI
RESPONDING TO HAIR-GATE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A PRODUCT WE
WOULD SELL AT 2  A.M.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> JUST ROLL THE TAPE AND I WILL
SHUT UP.
>> THE SALON OWES ME AN APOLOGY
FOR SETTING ME UP.
A SET UP BY A NEIGHBORHOOD SALON
I HAVE GONE TO FOR YEARS.
>> SHE IS TAKING RESPONSIBILITY
FOR BEING SCREWED OVER BY THE
SALON.
THAT’S INTERESTING.
>> I HAVE TO CLAP FOR HER.
>> IS THIS SEXIST?
TO CRITICIZE NANCY PELOSI OVER
THIS OR SEXIST TO BELIEVE SHE
DESERVES EXEMPTION BECAUSE OF
HER SEX AND NOT CRITITIZE IT?
VERY DIFFICULT QUESTION TO
ANSWER?
>> I WILL CRITICIZE IT.
I DIDN’T SEE THIS ONE COMING.
I DIDN’T SEE THIS EXCUSE COMING.
THAT’S ABSOLUTELY SHAMELESS
BRILLIANT!
MATT WHITLOCK, FOLLOW HIM ON
TWITTER.
HE PUT HER PRESS CONFERENCE TO
THE SOUND OF A CREDIT NEAR THE
END.
UNBELIEVABLE.
I THINK IT’S ALSO INTERESTING
SHE GOES ON TO GIVE AN INTERVIEW
SAYING IF THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
WEARING A MASK HE WILL KILL
PEOPLE.
IT PROVES THEY ARE JUST LIKE US.
THEY WANT TO BE BETTER THAN US
BUT THEY ARE NOT.
THEY HAVE TO GET THEIR HAIRCUT.
I THINK A LOT OF THE DATA COMING
IN SAYING THAT THE LOCKDOWNS
WERE NOT PRODUCTIVE AND NANCY
PELOSI IS OVERSEEING
A LEGISLATION NEGOTIATION WHERE
SALONS LIKE SHE WENT TO WOULD
NOT GET ANY MONEY.
SHE IS FORCING THEM TO OPEN JUST
FOR HER.
IN ADDITION, THE RULING CLASS
NOTION -- IF YOU ARE PART OF THE
RULING CLASS, THE RULES DON’T
APPLY TO YOU WHICH IS WEIRD.
I DON’T KNOW IN THAT’S AN
OXYMORON BUT IT SHOULD BE.
>> I THOUGHT I MADE THAT CLEAR
IN THE MONOLOGUE.
I WILL TRY BETTER NEXT TIME.
EMILY, I WONDER IF BEAUTY PARLOR
HAIR IS OVER-RATED.
WHY DO WE DEMAND WOMEN OF
A CERTAIN AGE TO GO TO A BEAUTY
PARLOR AND PUT UNDER MASSIVE
MACHINES.
I WILL SHOW YOU PICTURES.
THEY ARE FRIGHTENING.
LOOK AT THIS!
I FIND THIS QUITE DISTURBING.
WHERE DO YOU STAND ON THIS
SCANDAL THAT IS BREAKING THE
WORLDWIDE OPEN RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, I AM GRATEFUL FOR EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF THOSE MACHINES.
THESE GUYS HAVE SURFED THE
HYPOCRITICAL WAVES FOR DECADES.
THOSE WHO MAKES THE LAWS AND
THOSE WHO HAVE TO FOLLOW THEM.
RULES DON’T APPLY TO CONGRESS.
LAWS DON’T APPLY TO CONGRESS.
IT’S THE REASON WHY THE MAYOR
HERE OF SEATTLE GETS A 24-HOUR
OFF-DUTY SECURITY POLICE DETAIL
AND RESIDENTS GO LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIELD.
AND MAYOR DE BLASIO IN NEW YORK
ROLLS IN A CARAVAN TO THE GYM
AND THE REST HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
ENVIRONMENT ETHICES.
THIS IS TRANSPARENT.
WE EXPECT IT.
LAST MONTH OUR APPROVAL RATE OF
CONGRESS WAS 21%.
THERE IS A RECORD LOW OF 17.
WE TALK ABOUT PRIVILEGE AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE IT.
THIS IS NO MORE PRIVILEGED GROUP
IN THIS COUNTRY THAN THOSE
ENTRENCHED INCUMBENTS ON THE
HILL.
>> YOU’RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
JUAN, DO YOU AGREE WITH ME THAT
NANCY PELOSI SHOULD GO TO JAIL
AND SERVE 3 TO 5 YEARS FOR WHAT
SHE’S DONE?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU ARE SO
KIND.
I THINK YOU ARE GOING EASY ON
HER.
>> YES.
>> TO ME, I THOUGHT, BOY, IF SHE
WALKED THROUGH THAT PARLOR AND
WAS HOLDING A PINT OF ICE CREAM
THAT WOULD REALLY SET HER OFF.
THE PRESIDENT RAN AN AD ABOUT
IT.
LOOK NANCY PELOSI AND THE ELITE
ARE EATING FANCY ICE CREAM.
SHE OPENED HERSELF TO THIS
CHARGE OF HYPOCRISY.
EMILY, I THINK THE RICH ARE THE
ONES WHO ARE PRIVILEGED IN
AMERICAN SOCIETY BY FAR.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT GET TO
THE FRONT OF THE LINE AT DISNEY.
TO MY MIND, SHE DID A SERVICE TO
RIGHT WING COMMENTATORS WHO SAY
NANCY PELOSI YOU ARE
A HYPOCRITE.
I WILL SAY, SHE DIDN’T PUT
ANYBODY ELSE AT RISK.
THAT’S THE BEST ARGUMENT.
I DON’T LIKE WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT
THE SALON.
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY!
BUT HE DOESN’T PUT ANYBODY ELSE
AT RISK.
I CAN’T SAY THAT ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL CONVENTION
AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
I CAN’T SAY THAT ABOUT THE RALLY
IN TULSA ARE PEOPLE GOT SICK.
>> OR THE MASSIVE PROTESTS AND
THE RIOTING?
>> I DON’T KNOW --
>> NO POLITICIAN WAS LEADING
THAT.
THE BIGGEST HYPOCRISY OF THE DAY
GOES TO MELANIA TRUMP USING
PRIVATE EMAIL SERVER AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I THINK HILLARY CLINTON IS
EATING ICE CREAM AND LAUGHING.
>> SHE DIDN’T ACID WASH IT.
>> SHE WAS THE SECRETARY.
>> YES.
>> JESSE, I REALIZE YOU ARE
ANTI-WHAT?
ON ONE HAND THIS IS GREAT FOR
TRUMP AND BAD FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
-- THE DEMOCRATS.
>> I WANT TO WADE INTO THE
SEXISM THING.
IF DANA WILL VIRTUALLY HOLD MY
HAND.
I WILL MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
IT IS TRUE THAT WOMEN ARE MORE
BEAUTIFUL THAN MEN.
AND THAT WOMEN BECAUSE THEY ARE
MORE BEAUTIFUL MAYBE SPEND MORE
TIME MAINTAINING THEIR BEAUTY.
THAT WOMEN’S HAIR IS LONGER THAN
MEN’S HAIR AND NEEDS TO BE
MAINTAINED MORE AND AS YOU
MATURE, PERHAPS YOU MAY NEED TO
COLOR SAID HAIR MORE OFTEN.
AM I DOING OKAY SO FAR?
>> YES.
>> DANA DIDN’T SQUEEZE ME.
>> AS SOMEONE WHO GOES ON TV
ALMOST DAILY AS NANCY PELOSI
DOES AND AS A VERY POWERFUL
WOMAN, SHE NEEDS TO MAINTAIN
THAT LOOK.
WE ALSO AGREE THAT GAVIN NEWSOM
SHUTTING DOWN HAIR SALONS SEEMS
EXCESSIVE.
AS THE NUMBERS SHOW ON CABLE
NEWS, PERKS COME ALONG WITH
THAT.
WE ALL LOVE OUR PERKS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT EACH OF US
MAYBE HAS GONE ASTRAY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE REGULATION AND LET
OUR MASK SLIP DOWN BELOW OUR
MOUTH ON OCCASION.
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT NANCY PELOSI
DID.
SHE IS JUST LIKE THE REST OF US,
GREG.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS SHE
DOESN’T WALK THE WALK.
BECAUSE HE SHE IS A HYPOCRITE.
>> HANG ON, GREG.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT PERKS NANCY